Grandma's getting knocked the [__] out
[Music]
Starstruck just saying it
hello everybody my name is Glennie and
I'm here to answer the internet
I'll go money balls either one
I hate the word I [__] hate the word
hello everybody it's Glennie balls here
and I'm here to answer the internet
would you have sex with a dead person
for five minutes if you'd get your
laundry done and folded magically for
the rest of your life what's the
positional thing for a dead person's sex
because I've I've heard that I've heard
that their bodies like kind of cramp up
you can't really do anything
is it just missionary you just gotta do
it
I mean if it's like if it's like
give me like a warm picture like a dead
lady give me a warm like Audrey Hepburn
yeah no no a lot of no laundry for the
rest of your life yeah I'll [__] I want
you Hepburn still Audrey Hepburn would
you rather a fight Mike Tyson be sound
like him for the rest of your life so
I'm picturing myself at a bar what would
get a girl going more a Mike Tyson lisp
or the guy that got knocked the [__] out
by Mike Tyson in 2023
I'm gonna go with a lisp girls like
accents oh since girls love Australian
accents I'll say mine is my Mike Tyson
lisp it was your batter fighting Mike
Tyson would you rather [__] some [__]
the same position for the rest of your
life for only be able to jerk off to one
porn video I think one porn video I'm
I'm pretty set on uh there's a few like
I have in my Arsenal that I'm good to go
with and I'm
if I could just pick my favorite only
fans video if it's a girl I really like
I think I'd be good there's one girl
who's just a beautiful blonde most
perfect body I've ever seen in my life
if I could just pick one of her videos I
think I could live with that for the
rest of my life actually actually no
because I jerk off so much more than I
have sex but I'm not really a porn guy
as much as crazy as that sounds yeah how
Glenny you're on camera right now no I I
love I love the industry
but it's not like I'm like yeah I just
like to type in like I like to type in
categories like bachelorette party
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go with I'm gonna
go with [__] the same position
because like I said I jerk off way more
than I'm sex for 3 000 bucks would you
get your face Photoshop into a gay porn
if it was like a shitty Photoshop job
and you could tell sure I don't really
care and it'll be funny if it was like a
fake Photoshop you know when you look up
maybe you look up Megan Fox nudes in
like 2007 and there was just a blatantly
fake Megan Fox nude if that's what it
was I'd be down for that if it like
looks authentic
I'd maybe say no three I'm not in that
better shape for three thousand dollars
would you punch your grandma in the face
to [__] the girl of your dreams that's
the easiest question of all time I mean
obviously
I would knock that [__] out
so [__] you got like you got Jessica
Simpson Dukes of Hazzard walking in
Grandma's getting knocked the [__] out
is it weird to put on a team shirt to
watch a game of your house
listen on the outside it is do I do it
yeah you get excited you get in the zone
I mean if you if the Rangers were in the
Stanley Cup finals and I'm watching at
my house and I'm tuning in and I'm
getting a little drunk I'm gonna throw
on one of my old ccmgs just to feel
right doesn't matter does anybody care
no is it embarrassing when you really
look at it yes
it's so it's all in the fun it's all in
the pizzazz of the whole thing so just
do it would you rather give up The
Hungover breakfast sandwich or the drunk
Pizza I'm gonna go I'd rather give up
the drunk pizza because I gotta say I'm
not really a drunk Pizza Guy it doesn't
really do it for me when I'm drunk also
when I'm drunk I've been trying to eat
healthier recently I could eat anything
drunk like there's some times where I'll
make a grilled chicken and have it
waiting for me drunk I could live with
that but
like I'm not even The Hungover breakfast
sandwich the only thing I wouldn't give
up is The Hungover Diet Coke McDonald's
drive-through that's better to me than
the breakfast sandwich I would never
give that up for anything it's the only
reason I drink is to get the McDonald's
Diet Coke in the morning really like you
know when you wake up from drinking your
mouth is so dry and then just drive
right to McDonald's get a [__] small
Diet Coke and you stuck first sip it's
like it's it's like you're losing your
virginity for the first time it's crazy
would you rather eating felt as good as
sex but you wouldn't have a penis or sex
made you feel like you just ate a big
meal with bloating and weight gain I
feel like most of the time I have sex
anyway I'm already drunk so I feel like
I have that already so I may go with
that but then again I mean I eat a lot
felt as good as sex every single time
but then what would feel good though if
there's no dick
how many ah
I'd rather have the sex be a big meal I
think I could handle that anyway I
already picture sex because sex is a big
meal so that's fine I don't have as long
as cars when we have one do you think
you've had more sober sex or drunk sex
in your life
I mean it's like 99 trucks like a steady
99 I've never had a girlfriend so it's
mostly just
we asked that and I was like it's like
not even not even a debate I didn't
actually don't know if I've ever had
sober sex
I actually don't think I have if I've
never I've never been in a scenario with
a girl where I'm having sober sex like
it's not like the 50s where I'm going to
a drive-through movie theater and when
I'm 15 like I only meet girls at bars is
it weird for a guy to prefer Lube hand
jobs over blow jobs
um I know there is some there is
something special about a hand job when
you get it I don't know what I don't
know what the whole deal is is there
something special about it I'm gonna say
I don't think it's weird it's kind of
fun and then when when you feel for the
first time that their hands down there
it's a nice feeling so
it's cool I mean I say that as if it's
not cool with their mouths on if their
mouth's definitely cooler but
I don't think it's weird though would
you rather be 15 or 50 for the rest of
your life this is very interesting I
don't think 50 is too old 15 might be a
little young I will say I kind of for I
kind of miss the feeling of using a fake
ID but 15's too young to use a fake ID
and pretty much all I do is like
go out and [__] you can't do this as a
15 year old
so I guess I'm just gonna go 50 and 50
you got bills no I don't have bills
why not just be a 50 year old Newman in
my car and body I would fast forward oh
then 15. then forget that because 15's
like before sex like the best part of
life is playing cod with your friends so
I'd rather be 15. that's awesome I'll
take that back being 15 is the best like
if it's legitimately like that mindset I
thought you meant I'm transforming into
that right now no no no you would be oh
no so if I was just 15 in my in that 15
year old mindset the rest of my 15 years
old by far you go you just hang out with
your friends and play Call of Duty all
day if one of you gets a kiss every once
a month it's sick
if you could party with one sports team
in history who would it be
I mean I'm a Metson Rangers Fan so you
got the Rangers 94s Messier taking the
uh Stanley Cup to scores
but I feel like I can't 58 cannot pick
86 Mets but then you got 86 Giants you
got Lawrence Taylor who do you want to
party with more Keith Hernandez Lawrence
Taylor either way sounds like a lot of
blow I'll hang out I've never done below
but I'll party with him
please subscribe to the channel comment
below on other celebrities you'd like to
see and make sure you hit the Bell to
get notifications when new episodes come
out